mom and I we were one point thinking
about having another kid I had to get my
sperm check she had driven you to school
she had driven you to school and then we
were going to the sperm box got it we
get to the sperm doctor he goes here's
your cup I go cool
and he goes uh the Only Rule is you you
can't have masturbated within the last
48 hours I was like here's the cup
and your mom goes I've been with you for
two days she goes the only time I wasn't
with you is when I drove Jacob's school
I'm like
I feel like that's the worst time to do
it you know you're going in I know I'm
alone for at least 20 minutes
the next time we went back he gives me
the cup he goes you're good for the 48
hours I go good he goes what have you
been doing I go I was just in Vegas
what'd you do in Vegas I got a party he
goes give me the cup
I go why he goes your sperm is going to
come out like this
foreign
[Applause]